1968 war ich Angehöriger der 2. Jägerkompanie des Jägerbataillon 17
in Bad Radkersburg, mein Dienstplatz war Wachtmeister.
Meine Funktion war Kommandant einer Panzerabwehrgruppe.
Zu diesem Zeitpunk vom 20. August bis September
war ich gleichzeitig Ausbildungsleiter der Ausbildung von Kaderpersonal
und Rekruten am schweren Panzerabwehrrohr 66
In der Nacht vom 20. auf den 21. August
wurden wir Übungsweise alarmiert, das stand in keinen Zusammenhang
mit der dann folgenden Tschechienkrise und wir bezogen einen garnisonsnahen Verfügungsraum.
Dort bekam ich so gegen 3 Uhr in der Früh den Auftrag
mich beim Kasernenkommandanten am Thalerhof Graz, Graz Ost, zu melden, das tat ich.
Ich fuhr mit 2 Gmc und meinen Männern nach Graz und meldete mich dort beim Kasernenkommandanten.
Der meinte wir sollen warten, es kommen noch Befehle.
Ich ließ absitzen und wir warteten.
Am frühen Morgen kam der Brigardekommandant, der damalige Oberst Paulewicz
und fragte mich wo denn die restliche Kompanie sei.
Da sagte ich, ich weiß es nicht, die ist soviel ich weiß noch in Radkersburg im Verfügungsraum.
Etwa 2 Stunden später war auch die Kompanie dann geschlossen im Thalhof Ost.
Dort erfuhr ich dann erstmals vom Einmarsch der Sowjets in der Tschechoslowakei
und von der Möglichkeit, dass handstreichartig der Flugplatz in Graz Thalerhof auch
in Besitz genommen wird im Zusammenhang mit einer möglichen Lageentwicklung in Richtung Jugoslawien.
Ich sah dann auch untergezogen 3 M47 und ein Panzerkommandant erzählte mir,
dass er den Auftrag hätte bei anfliegenden Flugzeugen sich quer über die Rollbahn zu bewegen
um die Flugzeuge an der Landung zu hindern.
Wir erkundeten Alarmstellungen wie wir unsere Leute einsetzen also die Jägerzüge
und die Panzerabwehrwaffen, haben aber diese Stellungen nie besetzt sondern nur erkundet.
Nach einem etwa 50-60 Stündigen aufenthalt im Graz Thalerhof
bekamen wir den Befehl wieder einzurücken nach Bad Radkersburg.
In Bad Radkersburg angekommen wurden wir umfassend informiert über die Vorkommnisse in der Tschechoslowakei
und über die Möglichkeit, dass es auch im
steirischen Grenzraum zu Aktionen
im Zusammenhang mit einem möglichen Einmarsch in oder gegen Jugoslawien kommen könnte.
Dazu wurde befohlen, dass unsere Kaserne, auch die Kasernen in Straß, in Ferin und in Feldbach
zur Rundumverteidigung einzurichten sei.
Das haben wir getan und haben aus der Kaserne eine kleine Festung gemacht.
Dieser Zustand dauerte bis ungefähr 10. oder 15. September
und danach hatten wir Südbereitschaft,
jeden Mittwoch auf Donnerstag
und jeden Samstag und Sonntag.
Ab Oktober wechselten wir Verbände uns gegenseitig ab.
Einmal der Schwesterbataillon, einmal wir.
Aber wir sind noch ungefähr 6-7 mal über das Wochenende in Bereitschaft gesessen,
während dieser gesamten Zeit war immer scharfe Munition auf den LKWs verfügbar.
Die Verschläge wurden nicht geöffnet, also es wurde keine Munition an die Männer ausgegeben
aber wir waren immer Marschbereit für einen möglichen Einsatz.
Zufällig erfuhr ich auch, dass wir unter
Umständen auch vorgesehen gewesen wären
neben der ersten Jägerbrigade im Weinviertel eingesetzt zu werden,
was daran aber real war konnte ich als Wachtmeister nicht unbedingt beurteilen.